Transcriber: Merve Aydın
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Hepinize selamlar, sevgiler.
Bence Cevdet Ünlüer. Sizlerle beraber
aynı salonda bulunmayı çok isterdim.
İçinde bulunduğumuz şartları gereği
sizlerle ancak bu kamera
aracılığıyla iletişim kurabiliyorum.
Biraz kendimden bahsetmek istiyorum.
1981 Emirdağ doğumluyum.
Ailem Emirdağ’dan Eskişehir’e göç
ettiği için bütün eğitim hayatımı
Eskişehirde tamamladım .
İlkokul, ortaokul ve liseyi
Eskişehir’de bitirdim devamında
bilgisayar ve elektroniğe karşı olan
ilgimden dolayı da Elektrik Elektronik
Mühendisliği bölümünü kazandım.
Eskişehir Anadolu Üniversitesi,
Elektronik Mühendisliği bölümünden
2005 yılında mezun oldum.
Devamında ise IT sektörü ve yazılım
üzerine kariyer geliştirdim.
Bir yıl Eskişehir de çalıştıktan sonra 14
yıldır da TÜBİTAK’da çalışmaktayım.
Baş uzman araştırmacı olarak
görev yapmaktayım.
Oranında ortopedik
engeli mi bulunuyor?
Sağ ve sol ayaklarımında protezler var.
Bu protezler sayesinde gündelik hayatta
sorun yaşamadan işlerimi hayal ediyorum.
Protezler ile tanışmam ilk
kez 7 yaşındayken oldu.
Tabii ki protezleri kabullenme ve
kullanma süreci biraz zorlu bir süreçti.
Bu süreçte ailemin bana vermiş olduğu
destekle ve beni motive etmeleri
sayesinde yürümeyi ve kendi kendime
işlerimi yapabilmeyi başardım.
Ben başlarda çok zorluydu.
Ankara'ya gidip geliyorduk.
İşte Ankara'da o zamanlar
protez yapılıyordu.
Sabahları erken kalkıp 3 saatlik 4
saatlik yolu kat ettikten sonra
protezlerimiz için doktorlarla buluşup
testlerini yapıp daha sonra yürüme
denemeleri yapıyorduk.
Bu başta çok zor gelse de
ama okula gitmem için
bu protezin olması gerekiyordu.
Okul içerisinde gerek yürüyüşüm evin
içerisindeki yürüyüşüm için çok
önem arz ediyordu.
Bu protezler alıştım.
Alıştıktan sonra ilkokul ve ortaokulun
başlarına kadar
okul içerisinde ev içerisinde
hani çok sokakta gezemiyordum
O şekilde protez elimi kullanıyorum.
Babamla işte konuştuk dedim ya ben hani
okulun içerisinde ve
evin içerisinde protezleri
kullanabilirim ama
okula gidip gelirken işte senle olsun
işte annemle olsun işte o şekilde okula
gidip geliyordum.
Kendi kendime gelip gitmek
istiyorum demiştim.
O da sağ olsun işte o zamanlar tabii
elektrikli skuterlar yok.
Bana mopedden üç tekerlekli mopedi
üç tekerlekli hale getirdi ve onunla
beraber okula gidip gelmeye başladım.
Tek başıma gidip geliyodum.
Tabii bu bana biraz özgürlük kattı.
Özgüven kattı.
Mopedle hem okula gidip geliyordum hem de
fırsat buldukça Eskişehir’i geziyordum.
Eskişehir’i o zamanlar tabii google maps
yok ama eğer eskilerin google maps’ini
oluşturmuştum diyebilirim.
Gezmeye ve keşfetmeye karşı olan
hala devam ediyor.
Bugüne kadar birçok şehir gezdim,
yurtdışına çıktım ve Türkiye'deki bazı
dağlara çıktım.
Doğa fotoğrafıyla da ilgileniyorum.
Başlarda gittiğim yerleri belgelemek
amaçlı çektiğim
fotoğrafçılığı da bayağı ilerlettim.
Doğa fotoğrafı çekmekten çok hoşlanıyorum.
Tabii o fotoğrafı çekmek için epeyce
gezmek ve vakit doğada
vakit geçirmek gerekiyor.
Bir ortopedik engelli olarak doğada vakit
geçirirken gezerken öncelikle bazı şeylere
çok dikkat etmeniz gerekiyor.
Sizlere biraz onlardan bahsedebilirim
Evvela uzun süreli bir
geziye çıkacaksınız.
Protezlerinizin herhangi bir
sorunu olmaması gerekiyor.
Örneğin bir haftalık bir geziye
gittiğinizde eğer protezlerinizde bir
sorun yaşarsanız oralarda epey bir sizin
için sancılı saatler geçer.
Öncelikle yani protezin, kemerlerin
olsun bu işte civataları olsun.
Bunları bir gözden geçirip daha sonra
yola çıkmayı tercih ediyorum.
İkinci bir zorluksa kendinizi çok
yormamanız gerekiyor eğer kendinizi çok
yorar ilk günlerde bütün enerjinizi
harcarsınız.
devamında hiçbir şey yapmamaya bilirsiniz.
Gezi ve seyahatte elinizde otomobil tercih
etmeniz de çok büyük fayda var.
Çünkü otomobiller sizi varmak istediğiniz
son noktaya kadar götürmektedirler.
Eğer otomobil bulamıyorsanız demiryolu
ve havayolu tercih etmenizde fayda var
arkadaşlar.
Demiryolunda engelliler için bir
birim bulunmakta
Keza havalimanında ve engelliler
için bir birim bulunmakta.
Siz demiryoluna veyahutta
havalimanına varlığınızda bu birimlerde
çalışan arkadaşlar sizi karşılayıp
koltuk numaralarınızın bulunduğu
yere kadar sizi götürüyorlar
inişte de tekrar sizi karşılıyorlar.
Bu noktada yani çok büyük
faydaları oluyor.
Gelelim ben bu ulaşım yöntemlerini
kullanarak nerelere gittiğim,
Neleri gördüm ve çektiğim fotoğraflarla
size bunları biraz aktarmak istiyorum?
Fethiye Babadağ'dan yamaç paraşütü yaptım.
Yamaç paraşütü atlandığı
iki tane pist var.
Bu iki piste de minibüslerle
çıkılabiliyor.
Ordaki arkadaşlar size yardımcı oluyorlar.
Bence burada yamaç paraşütü yapmanız
için hiç bir engel bulunmuyor.
Fotoğraflarda hemen göstereyim.
Nemrut Dağı'na çıktım.
Nemrut Dağı’na giderken Elazığ Havaalanını
kullandım, Elazığ üzerinden ordan
Adıyaman’a Adıyaman’dan da
Nemrut’a gittim.
Nemrut Dağı'na vardıktan sonra belirli
bir kısımda rampa var.
o rampayı yürümekte zorlanabilirsiniz,
eğer yanınızda arkadaşınız
varsa onun yardımıyla
Nemrut Dağı'na çıkabilirsiniz.
Ankara'dan İzmir'e trenle gidebilirsiniz.
Tren garlarında bulunan engelli
masalarından yardım alabilirsiniz.
İzmir'e vardığınızda.
İzmir’de metro bulunuyor metroyu
kullanabilirsiniz.
İzmir’de Kordon’da gezebilirsiniz.
Eğer bir gibi yüzmeyi seviyorsanız.
İzmir’in ilçelerinde de yüzmeye
gidebilirsiniz.
Yine kendi aracınızla ya da hızlı trenle
Eşkişehir’i de görebilirsiniz,
Eskişehir içerisinde birçok yeri
gezebilirsiniz.
Eskişehir'de tramvay bulunmakta.
Eskişehir tramvayla her
tarafını gezebilirsiniz.
Eğer ilçelerine de gitmek isterseniz
çok ilginç bir ilçesi var.
Han ilçesi. Han ilçesinde yeraltı
şehirlerini görebilirsiniz.
Çanakkale'ye gidebilirsiniz.
Çanakkale her ne kadar düz
bir yer olsa da ulaşım
açısından bazı zorlukları bulunuyor.
Kendi aracınızla gitmenizi tavsiye ederim.
Çanakkale'ye gittiğinizde şehitlikleri
görebilirsiniz.
Kapadokya’ya gidebilirsiniz, Kapadokya’da
balonlara binmenizde hiçbir problem yok.
Sepetler gerçekten balonun sepetleri
gerçekten sizler için güvenli ben denedim.
Türkiye'de gezecek en güzel yerlerden
biri de İstanbul.
İstanbul’a Ankara’dan hızlı
trenle gidebilirsiniz.
Devamında İstanbul’da çeşitli
ulaşım yöntemleri var.
Bunların hepsini kullanabilirsiniz.
Vapura binerken, inerken biraz
dikkat lazım.
O kısımlarını engellilerle ilgili
bazı noktalar düşünülmemiş.
Müzelerini gezebilirsiniz.
Müzeleri çok güzel ve içerisi engellilere
göre tasarlanmış.
Tamamen engellilere göre
tasarlanmış diyebilirim.
Buralarda güzel vakit geçirebilirsiniz.
Yurt dışına çıkabilirsiniz,
yurt dışına çıkmadan önce
pasaportunu almanız gerekiyor.
Pasaport işlemlerini tamamladıktan sonra
havaalanına gittiğinizde
yardım masasındaki arkadaşlar size
yardımcı oluyor,
uçağınıza kadar götürüyorlar,
in-binlerde karşılıyorlar.
Pasaport kontrolü kısmından
VIP’den geçebilirsiniz.
Yardım masasının desteğiyle
yurt dışında birçok yere gelebilirsiniz.
Yurtdışında eğer yabancı diliniz
varsa hiç bir problem çekmezsiniz.
Metrosundan faydalanabilirsiniz.
Trenlerinden faydalanabilirsiniz.
Londra.
Münih.
Barselona.
Zürih.
Amsterdam.
Budapeşte.
Merakım ve protezlerim sayesinde
birçok ülke ve şehir gördüm.
Yeni kültürlerle tanışmak dünyayı daha
iyi anlama yardımcı oldu.
Sizlere tavsiyem sırt çantanızda
yollara koyulun.